[Musique]
pour
euh c'est
[Musique]
ok ok ok ok ok
continuer
[Musique] [
Musique] ok
le monde le
monde
[Musique]
va bien maintenant c'est bien ouais
ok ok haut haut
haut
[Musique]
avant
ici
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
avant [
Musique] [
Musique]
ok [
directement [
Musique]
pour
[Musique]
spe
all [
Musique]
bien
[Musique]
les gars c'est
pour
hé
[Musique]
toi on
continue on
[Musique] on
continue
[Musique]
ok euh très
bien ok ok on
soupe tous combien de temps nous avons maintenant euh euh
environ 30 minutes 30 minutes ok pouvons-
nous aller voir
[Musique] euh
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à gauche [
Musique]
euh trop de brouillard il faut descendre un
peu
[Musique]
un peu
ok c'est bon tu dis ok ok
maintenant que diriez-vous maintenant un peu à
gauche gauche
gauche Principal
[Applaudissements]  ]
La rue
[Applaudissements]
c'est ok ok
quoi
[Musique]
et pourrions-nous passer du haut à la porte
verticalement à la porte CL la porte ouais
par-dessus euh par-
dessus par-dessus par-dessus
ok
soit
[Musique]
avant
on s'arrête ici
station euh  ceux euh maintenant c'est bon ou tu
dois te retourner non
[Musique]
non
d'accord on pourrait faire une
urne à 180° stationnaire comme ça mais si
on peut garder le nez euh 8
180° en arrière ok
tourne
[Musique]
si on peut
vas-y, maintenant, ok, tu veux bien, bien, bien
[Musique]
trop bas, tu sais pas trop [
Musique]
bas, c'est bien
maintenant, d'accord [Musique]
continue euh [Musique] ok euh ok
avant [Musique
]
on
continue, continue,
continue
ok ok,
pouvons-nous le faire
encore une fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
ok
ok ok encore
maintenant ok
bien vers
le bas
B
ok ok
très bien ok
tout
[Musique]
euh
pour [
Musique]
Musique] [
[Musique]
comme ça
très
bien